we're going to begin this weekend
talking about the coronavirus the
country faces
huge challenges on multiple fronts
there's gridlock in congress over
federal unemployment benefits set to
expire today for about 30 million
americans
for the fourth day in a row the death
toll in the coronavirus crisis
was more than one thousand people eureka
and all this coming as hurricane a
hurricane bears down on the eastern u.s
it's likely
to hammer states already badly affected
by the pandemic
we start this morning with that looming
storm threat with chief weathercaster
lonnie quinn at wcvs tv lonnie good
morning
where is this hurricane good morning
okay this is moving toward the bahamas
and then possibly towards the uh
coastline of florida but let's take a
peek at the current stats because while
you were sleeping last night
this storm has bumped up now to
hurricane isaiah's it's got 80 mile per
hour winds moving to the northwest at 17
miles per hour so it's a fast mover as
of right now
350 miles to the southeast of the
bahamas now we believe sometime late
tonight or tomorrow it bumps up to a
category two
maybe making a landfall somewhere around
nassau maybe freeport
that was devastated by dorian just last
year and then it moves towards the
florida coastline but sort of curves
away
again the skinny red line is offshore of
the florida coast but you got to watch
the cone the cone does include the
florida coastline and the cone also
includes a good portion of the northeast
now we may have a landfall
around the outer banks of north carolina
as a cat one on tuesday
by wednesday it's somewhere around cape
cod maybe
even affecting the big cities of
philadelphia and new york because again
the skinny red line's offshore but the
cone includes the big cities and this is
the wind field
as for florida as of right now and this
could change
but the biggest win field would be a
tropical storm force wind around fort
pierce which is about 39 miles per hour
and then it pushes offshore so
as of right now it looking good it looks
okay for florida but you got to keep
your eye on this because they change
all the time at the last minute so vlad
let's go back to you
all right lani thank you very much